Oh, God.
He went downrange in a
bomb suit with a crowbar.
I mean, cool.
We would clown this
movie so much in training
and just do the most outlandish s---
because that's exactly what he did.
Hey, everyone, Jay Ly here.
13-year Navy explosive
ordnance disposal, or EOD, vet.
Did four combat deployments,
three to Afghanistan
and one to East Africa.
Today we'll be looking
at bomb-disposal scenes
in movies and TV and
judge how real they are.
That thing is apparently
the Cadillac of trolleys.
Can I say 100% that this
wouldn't be entertained?
No, because it might, but what I do know
is there are probably a dozen other ways
to attack this device from inside the bus.
I mean, something rudimentary
as getting a stick with some film,
so we can take an X-ray of the device
so we can actually see what's going on.
Harry: Jack, I'm going to
need you to look at the wire.
Harry, it's covered.
He is talking on a radio and/or a phone
right next to this thing.
It's electronically initiated.
They don't know if that energy
will cause that device to fire or not.
So that whole thing is
not realistic whatsoever.
I can't bypass! It'll fire.
S---, it's a collapsible circuit.
Yeah, collapsing circuits are real.
There's two or more detonators,
and when you cut one,
the other one will fire.
It's common for us to train to that.
It's very unlikely to encounter that.
In, well, at least in
Afghanistan, in my experience,
we didn't encounter a lot
of collapsing circuits.
It was mainly pressure
plates, stuff like that.
Very simple circuits.
Officer: Howard Payne,
Atlanta PD bomb squad.
Jack, I want you to get
out of there and sit tight.
We're going to go after the source.
No, they should 100% do
something to this device
and not just solely rely on
the bomber helping them out.
There are tools we have
to disrupt an IED and a component,
so it'll disrupt the firing train.
It'll disrupt all the circuitry
and separate components remotely,
and then we'll go down,
check the disruption,
and then separate components
further and do our thing.
Jack, I believe he is
a bomb-disposal officer with the LAPD.
He should know these
component-recognition things
and be able to identify
how this device works,
or at least have a good idea of it.
This definitely gets a zero
because he knows better,
and he should have taken an action.
He should have brought a
tool down there with him.
He could have taped it right next to it
and disrupted that
thing right off the bus.
We got under three minutes
left. What do I do first?
Pressure sensors. I
activated it when I sat down.
If I get up, my car explodes.
This is already hokey because he sat down,
and now it's armed. And there's a timer.
In movies and TV, they often
incorporate these big timers
where it's counting
down to the detonation.
But in all reality, it's mainly
a safe-and-arm-type mechanism.
If I'm a bomb emplacer, I
need to be able emplace it
and then safely get away.
So there's a timer,
but you're not going to
see this giant clock.
It's like, "You have five
minutes before you die."
Orange, yellow, green.
Colors don't matter. What
I need you to do is tell me
which one is hot to the touch.
The warm wire versus cold wires,
you can make a circuit
with the proper resistance,
so none of the wires are warm.
So, like, the movie
tropes of the warm wire
or the colors of the
wires is a total farce.
I can go to Home Depot, Lowe's,
whichever hardware store,
your hardware store of choice,
get any color wire I
want, and put it in here.
Take the small box out of
the kit and turn it on.
That kit probably looked like something
I would pull tools from
in a special-operations-forces
environment.
From my experience in Afghanistan,
it was all special operations forces
or naval special warfare.
We flew in helicopters somewhere, landed,
and ran to a target, right,
or walked a great distance
to get to a target.
You really want to limit
what you have on your body.
So, yeah, we're not going
to be carrying around
briefcases and backpacks
just full of tools.
Just cut it in the middle.
The orange wire between the two clamps.
I don't want to get into
that specifically in detail
because that is how we
attack certain things.
But yeah, those clamps,
they're for a very specific
purpose for multiple detonators,
and you would need another
item that he doesn't have there
to do diagnostic work
on that type of device.
You would need a little bit more time,
I mean, a lot more training
than just him saying,
"Oh, yeah, clamp it on the warm wire
and then cut in between it."
There's a lot of testing you have to do
before you can cut a wire.
But yeah, the whole setting,
him sitting down in it,
arming it, and then
having this opportunity
to render it safe, yeah, you wish.
So yeah, we'll give him a
two. We'll give him a two.
How it was set up and how it
was in place, totally legit.
He had a Claymore.
He put it on top of the Grand
Slam bomb, huge British bomb.
Claymores are used all
over. They're already wired.
They're premade to be
set up as booby traps.
That's what they're for. So
he just had the trip wire,
put something that he thought
one of these people chasing
him, idiots, would grab.
There are 100% bomb-detection dogs,
and in this clip, those dogs, I believe,
are going for human detection.
They're going for sniffing out Rambo,
not necessarily sniff out
explosive hazards in the woods.
And even if they were, those
dogs are running full speed.
That's like essentially
you trying to sniff
a hot dog in the corner while
sprinting down the hallway,
like hyperventilating essentially.
It's never going to happen.
Would the blast wave be that extended?
I mean, it was drawn
out to have that effect.
The explosive component
in there is torpex.
They added aluminum into the
composition of that explosive
to extend the blast.
But with that being said,
that's like a nuclear blast wave
that is just kind of continuing to go out.
It would be really big and done.
That blast wave would've
killed a lesser man.
Not John Rambo.
The explosive component
in there is torpex.
It's about 50% stronger than
TNT. And that's only the blast.
Frag goes exponentially
further than blast does.
So yeah, he is definitely within that.
This is probably the most realistic clip
as far as how things function
and how people think.
Man, I might give "Rambo" an eight.
He's knocked two because of survival.
That's hokey at best, even for John Rambo.
I got it!
It's a cylinder cipher! D-U-N-N.
It's my last name. It knows who I am.
If someone is just going to make
an improvised nuclear
device like this cipher,
anything is possible.
There's many ways that
nuclear weapons are armed.
Can't get into any specifics.
There's state-sponsored,
and then there's non-state-sponsored.
State-sponsored are going to have
all kinds of different protocols in place,
safeties, what have you, arming sequences.
Non-state-sponsored, if someone is just
going to make an improvised nuclear device
like this cipher, it can be
armed when it hears your voice,
when my voice, whatever the case may be.
Benji: I speak without a mouth.
I fly through the air
without wings. What am I?
An echo.
That's it! That's it, that's it.
Ugh. I can't. I can't even with this one.
This is ... he's talking to it.
How does he know if he
answers this question,
it's not going to go off?
It's empty.
Apparently it was a mud suck, right?
A hoax IED or a hoax device.
In real life, hoaxes are actually
very common, very common,
especially in Iraq and Afghanistan.
They were utilized
as intelligence-gathering
devices, essentially.
They'd put it in the road. Totally fake.
Just something that would
key up an EOD response,
and then they would be watching
and videotaping the whole procedure.
Despite all of the craziness
that was in the scene,
using a hoax to gather
intelligence on people
and to learn more about
them, absolutely true.
We'll give this one a eight,
up there with "Rambo."
Oh, God.
We would clown this movie
so much in training.
Like, we would just
pretend we're this dude
and just do the most outlandish s---
because that's exactly what he did.
He's attacking a VBIED,
which is a vehicle-borne
improvised explosive device.
Walking up to a VBIED without a tool,
an explosive tool, an
energetic tool, or anything,
not even a pole line or anything
to prosecute this vehicle,
is just dumb.
He went downrange in a
bomb suit with a crowbar.
I mean, cool.
They would probably send a robot down
with a tool first, right?
Especially because yeah,
that's a lot of HE.
A VBIED is no joke.
I mean, even the guys on the
wall, his security element,
they'd probably die if
that thing went off.
What the hell is he doing?
Dead.
He could have died a half
dozen to a dozen ways
in this clip alone.
Not to mention the whole movie.
Kicking it, randomly
opening the trunk by hand,
opening the hood by hand,
turning the windshield wipers on,
yanking random wires underneath the hood.
Like, any one of those could
have set that thing off.
Yeah, I think he removed his headset.
Please put your headset back on.
The most realistic thing in
there was the radio thing.
He actually took his headset
off so he could focus
and get his thought process going.
And then when they asked
him to put it back on,
yeah, that's probably the
response that you'd get
from an EOD tech.
We definitely render safe IEDs by hand.
I've done it,
and it's not ideal.
We want to go as remote as possible
because of the risk of
something going off.
But yeah, he could have done
a lot more with his hands,
like cut that cord,
detonating cord right out of the gate.
I forgot how many 155s,
but that's what was in
the trunk of that car
once he saw the main charge,
and that's what he should
be going after anyway.
Just reckless abandon.
Yeah, it's totally Hollywooded up.
The only realistic thing was
the communication aspect of it.
He gets a one. One out of 10.
Three miles underwater,
the water's crystal clear,
so I mean, that's ...
no, there's no way.
My fourth team, I was on a
mine-countermeasure team,
but it was underwater sea mines
and underwater IEDs and stuff like that.
This is supposed to be a nuke
that has fallen into the abyss.
It's a big deal when we go
to 200 feet of seawater.
We're definitely not going to
do free ascent to the bottom.
There's always descent lines.
We establish a safe area.
Yeah, he doesn't have any
search tools whatsoever.
He just has his eyeballs and
a flare, which is insane.
And that's just the diving aspect,
so we haven't even gotten
to the EOD part of it.
Hiram: He made it.
Oh, my God.
We'll go step by step.
The communication is totally wazoo.
It's three miles underwater.
What RF signal can penetrate
three miles' worth of water?
We do have very rudimentary
ways of communicating,
i.e., a float on the top of the water
that's connected to us via a
line, and we'll just pull it,
and the certain number of
pulls means a certain thing.
So we communicate like that
in a bottom-line-centric environment
where we're taking seismic
and magnetic precautions.
But yeah, nuke, that is a
totally different ballgame.
You have to cut the ground
wire, not the lead wire.
Without getting into any super specifics
on nuclear-weapons design,
we would've researched this ordnance item:
this is exactly how you render it safe,
if we want to separate components,
separate the fuse from it.
Sometimes we do that explosively,
sometimes we do it mechanically,
and then we'd just raise it
up and bring it to the beach
and exploit it on the surface.
I'd have to give that a big
fat doughnut for realism,
a zero, because that's not at all
how nuclear weapons function.
Here! McIntyre, can you hear me?
I love this show. It's so funny.
Unexploded ordnance, UXO.
Those are very common because
sometimes fuses just dud out,
and it's still a threat
because we just don't
know the condition of it.
Why did it not go off?
Is it a time? Is it a proximity thing?
Is it a delay that just
hasn't gone all the way yet?
So, very much a concern,
less so for everyone
else that's behind cover,
but mainly for the guys
that are right on top of it.
Heartbeat's regular.
[hissing]
You spring a leak?
It stopped ticking.
It is definitely plausible
to use a stethoscope
to examine a suspected clockwork fuse.
Seems hokey, but yeah,
that is old-school legit.
It was a thing.
For old bombs like that,
they had clockwork mechanisms in the fuse
that you could hear ticking down.
We don't see that a lot anymore.
That was a lot of training in school,
just to get the exposure to it.
It's a propaganda bomb!
Leaflets are definitely employed.
They were dropped in all over Europe
during World War II.
They were employed in, I
mean, North Korea, Vietnam.
Leaflets are definitely a
type of psychological warfare
or even just a means to
communicate with a population
that just is confined to an area.
But yeah, I'd give it a
solid seven for realism.
Granted, two random people
would not be working this bomb,
but yeah, so we've gotta
dock it a little bit.
I just don't know why they didn't have any
bomb-squad people.
So, on the side of the timer,
there should be a serial number.
That'll tell me which
wire y'all need to cut.
"Archer" here is showing
an inexperienced person
being coached through this whole ordeal,
like many other movies and TV shows.
It would be almost impossible
unless it was set up
exactly how the manufacturer
wanted it to be set up.
If that's the case, totally doable, right?
I can walk you through
anything. It's like, OK, cool,
how many wires are there,
what colors are they?
You ready?
Lana: God dammit, Archer!
First letter is B.
Bravo.
Thanks. Second letter is --
M as in Mike?
Oh, my God, that is so spot
on as far as communications,
especially when s---'s hitting the fan.
Oh, I can relate.
You have radio frequencies,
you have interference,
you have distance, you have
other things in the way,
so your signal can be degraded.
Everyone is getting
ramped up in this episode,
but in real life, when stuff is going on
and comms are an issue,
you just really stay calm
and cool and collected on the radio.
That way, even if it is a weak signal,
you can still hear what's being said.
Archer: I'm doing it, God!
Lana: Oh, my God. Ray!
Ray: What's going on?
The timer sped up!
The trope here with the
green wires being cut
and speeding up the
clock is just erroneous
because it makes no sense to
have that feature in there
unless you're trying to
create some type of anxiety,
and in real life, trust me,
if you're faced with a live explosive
that can detonate at any action,
keeping that at bay is already
going to be difficult enough.
So yeah, at the end of the day,
people want their things to go off.
So that's how they make them.
I'll give them a four.
The communication piece, that
was hilariously accurate.
Towards the general
direction of the mountain.
The robot rarely finds
what you're looking for.
They're in Helmand, which,
I was also in Helmand.
Helmand Province in Afghanistan.
And yeah, robots are awesome.
I didn't see the robot
go down with a tool.
Tool in, tool out, that's what we do.
That's what's preached
from day one in EOD school.
The robot has cutters
on it, it has grippers,
it can separate components,
whatever the case may be.
And so if it did find something,
it could countercharge it
or they could set it down.
No!
At the end of the day, that
is what a robot is for.
They're expendable devices.
If worst comes to worst,
they find something by functioning it,
it blows up, not a human being.
The entire team was standing
out in front of the vehicles.
That's totally not what would happen.
They would be inside their
vehicle driving this robot.
That way, you have mitigation
from fragmentation coming at you.
At least be behind the
vehicle, for God's sake.
I need you to keep your head still.
Don't nod.
This is a clothespin switch.
Very old and very rudimentary,
very easy to defeat.
Nick, the EOD operator,
should have seen that.
He identified that it's
a pull. Cool. Cut it.
Just cut it and be done with it.
But he did the thing of holding his head.
You tell someone that
they're connected to a line
with a bunch of explosives,
they're going to freak out.
That's one of the rare times
where you can actually attack a switch.
It's a very clear cut.
That could have been
handled way differently,
and then everyone would've survived.
It's tough. A lot of EOD
procedures and tactics
are written in blood, just like this.
The survivors are like,
OK, this is exactly what they encountered.
Over the radio, this is what was said.
Now we have our new set of TTPs
so it doesn't happen again.
I'll give this one of
five. It's got some stuff,
some super-hokey stuff,
but all in all, not bad.
Bombs aren't on the same fire line.
I have to defuse them individually.
How long is that going to take?
I gotta find them and then
dismantle them. 30 minutes.
There's just, like, a chunk
of high explosive taped to a pipe.
EOD would see that and,
boom, and make a call,
and everyone would get out of there
except for one other person,
him and one other security person,
and then I'm going to take
immediate action on that device.
And immediate is immediate.
It's not 30 minutes.
He was using a mirror for whatever reason.
I'm not going to use an inspection mirror
when I have my eyeballs and I
can see all the way around it.
So yeah, that's kind of hokey.
He's got NODs on his helmet,
so that's cumbersome,
especially when he's working on that one
that was at head level.
His NODs could hit it,
and if there's an anti-move
thing on there, boom.
He just functioned it, as designed.
So I would take my helmet
off, so there's nothing,
no obstructions that could
potentially hit this device.
If he's the only one there,
yeah, that's what he's got to do.
It's because it's threat assessment
of what's going to kill me right now.
That's an enemy combatant.
He's probably going to
kill me if he sees me.
So that needs to be taken care of first.
But yeah, he would have
at least one shooter with
him a little bit away,
so when I'm working, I
can be focused on this.
They could've classed it up
a little bit, but all good.
Bingo.
He did use ceramic scissors at the end.
I thought that was a nice touch. Granted,
he used ceramic scissors
instead of diagonal cutters,
and typically when wires
are coiled up like that,
there's two of them, and he cut them both.
He could have smooshed the two wires
that are conductive
together and set it off.
Yeah, there's a lot of hokey stuff.
So yeah, it's gotta be low. Low three.
John: What are you doing?
Batman: I can get it out over the bay.
The plausibility of having a bomb
that is unable to be rendered safe,
it's all a matter of time, really.
If time is not an object,
then yeah, you can spend
the time and the diligence
and really get it disassembled
to where it's demil'd.
So now you have to weigh,
can I render this safe in a
minute and 30 seconds or not?
And the answer's probably no, right?
Because especially with a device
as sophisticated as
that was supposed to be,
your best case is you have a minute and 30
to get this as far away
from everyone as possible.
Yeah, water has a great tamping effect
because it cannot compress.
It really depends on what
the actual explosive,
the nuclear yield of this bomb was
and how deep it was able to go.
The mission of EOD is protection
of personnel and property.
So yeah, getting that device
out in a way, moving it,
relocating it, even if
it's to your own demise,
is what we would do
for the sake of protecting
personnel and property.
Is it a nine? Can Batman be a nine?
I'll give it a nine.
I like to think his actions were genuine
of Navy EOD.
I'm going to have to say my
favorite bomb-disposal scene
of all time has got to be
the scene in "MacGruber."
Totally outlandish, but so funny.
But if I'm going for
something with good sentiment,
then today, we saw that Batman video,
and I think that really captured
the quintessential mindset of Navy EOD
about eliminating a threat
to civilian population
and mitigating the risk
and moving it away.
Hey, everyone, thanks for watching.
If you thought this video
was the bomb, pun intended,
go ahead, watch the next video.